[Musique]
pour parler entre les autorités
éthiopiennes et les rebelles du Tigré se
poursuivent un aérobie au Kenya après un
premier rang de négociation en Afrique
du Sud objectif des discussions
transformer le cessez-le-feu en accord
de paix durable la correspondance un
aérobie dans un instant et puis
l'ouverture de la cop27 à charmelcher en
Égypte la 27e Conférence des Nations
Unies sur le climat s'est réuni avec
pour objectif de tenir ses engagements
le continent africain suivi les
conséquences des promesses non tenues
par les pays les plus pollueurs nous
irons à Saint Louis au Sénégal où vous
constaterez par vous-même les dégâts du
réchauffement climatique et nous
donnerons la parole à une ingénieur dont
l'invention a changé la vie des
agriculteurs ce sera à la fin de ce jour
un Sukhoi 27 25 dollars mais congolaise
à survolé dans la matinée l'espace
aérien rwandais sans autorisation c'est
ce qu'affirme qu'il Galli la République
démocratique du Congo qui a déployé ce
dimanche deux avions de chasse russe
pour lutter contre le M23 a parlé d'un
incident un incident dans un contexte
très tendu entre les deux pays cela
correspondance à Kigali de Clément
Jérôme le gouvernement rwandais parle
d'une provocation inacceptable suite au
bref survol non autorisé dans l'avion de
chasse congolais qui gagne à publier un
communiqué à la mi-journée affirmant que
les autorités de Kinshasa ont reconnu
l'incident et qu'aucune action militaire
n'a été prise par le Rwanda l'appareil
et donc retourner en RDC à la base de
Goma une ville frontalière qui
cristallise les tensions entre les deux
pays le 31 octobre dernier plusieurs
milliers de personnes ont manifesté
contre le Rwanda qui gagne et
régulièrement accusé de soutenir le
groupe armé M23 qui gagne du terrain
dans l'Est du Congo le Rwanda réfute ses
accusations ces derniers jours des
milliers de se sont engagés dans l'armée
nationale à Goma dans le cadre d'une
mobilisation générale alors malgré
l'expulsion de l'ambassadeur rwandais de
Kinshasa il y a environ une semaine les
relations diplomatiques semble maintenir
entre les deux pays les deux ministres
des Affaires étrangères se sont
rencontrés le 5 novembre en Angola pour
relancer le dialogue politique et
reprendre la feuille de route de Luanda
l'acte 2 pour parler entre les autorités
éthiopiennes et les rebelles du tigre
après un premier rang de négociations en
Afrique du Sud les discussions se
poursuivent à nairobie et l'enjeu est de
taille permettre de transformer le
cessez-le-feu en accord de paix durable
les médiateurs sur place sont optimistes
la correspondance au Kenya de Bastien
renoué il s'agit d'un premier pas dans
la bonne direction après la signature de
ce cessez-le-feu entre le front de
libération du peuple du Tigré et l'armée
fédérale d'Addis-Abeba ce sont les mots
du négociateur en chef de l'Union
africaine après l'ouverture d'une
liaison téléphonique entre 10 à Beba et
le tigree qui permet de d'avancer sur
les négociations des mots prononcés
alors qu'une nouvelle session de
négociation a ouvert ce lundi année
Robbie entre les membres du TPLF et le
gouvernement d'Addis-Abeba des
négociations qui devraient permettre de
trouver des solutions à deux points clés
de l'accord à savoir comment organiser
la démobilisation des troupes tigrénes
et comment permettre l'ouverture d'un
corridor commentaires en direction du
tigree il faut savoir que l'aide
humanitaire est absolument nécessaire
dans cette région 90% de la population a
besoin d'aide qu'il s'agisse de soins ou
encore de nourriture mais il faudra
faire vite l'accord prévoit que le TPLF
a seulement 30 jours pour réaliser
toutes les conditions d'Addie Saba sans
quoi la paix ne serait pas possible mais
les négociateurs ici ont de l'espoir
notamment ou kenyata l'ancien président
kenyan qui supervise les négociations il
espère que la prochaine rencontre pourra
avoir lieu à mekelé la capitale du
tigree et que la suivante sera organisée
à Addis-Abeba ou pourront être célébrés
des accords de paix
on en vient à la 27e Conférence des
Nations Unies sur le climat elle s'est
ouverte ce dimanche à charme elle cher
en Égypte avec une question sur toutes
les lèvres sera-t-elle enfin la COP des
promesses tenues il ne s'agit pas que de
prendre des engagements ou de les
renforcer mais de les respecter c'est ce
qu'attendent les Africains qui subissent
de plein fouet les effets du
réchauffement climatique Caroline
lambolie
des actions pas des mots c'est le mot
d'ordre pour les pays africains lors de
cette coop en Egypte
si nous obtenons cette décision sur le
financement pour l'adaptation ce serait
la cerise sur le gâteau
ne nous donnez pas plus de financement
s'il vous plaît juste concernant le
financement que vous nous avez déjà
promis dites nous simplement comment
vous comptez faire rencontrons-nous deux
fois par an organisons des consultations
soyons transparents rendons des comptes
ce sera déjà un bon début
sénégalais Macky Sall il a appelé les
participants à faire l'histoire faire
l'histoire
en tenant nos engagements
tous nos engagements
dont celui convenu de 100 milliards de
dollars par an pour soutenir les efforts
d'adaptation des pays en développement
et qui peine à être entièrement réalisé
les pays pauvres insistaient depuis des
mois pour que la question des pertes et
dommages soit abordée lors de cette
coque ils ont obtenu gain de cause la
question était inscrite sur l'agenda ce
dimanche
les pays africains sont responsables de
moins de 4% des émissions mondiales de
gaz à effet de serre mais ils sont très
exposés aux conséquences du
réchauffement climatique
lors de la dernière Cope à Glasgow les
pays riches avaient bloqué une
proposition pour mettre en oeuvre un
mécanisme d'indemnisation pour les pays
pauvres ils ont préféré prolonger de
trois ans le dialogue sur le sujet
vous l'avez entendu les pays africains
sont ceux qui polluent moins et qui se
visse le plus les affres du
réchauffement climatique en voici un
exemple à Saint Louis au Sénégal c'est
une des villes les plus touchées par la
montée du niveau de la mer en 2018 le
gouvernement a lancé un projet pour
déplacer les populations des quartiers à
risque dans une nouvelle cité mais vous
allez voir que plus de 4 ans après le
projet n'est pas encore sorti de terre
reportages de Sam Brad pis et Iman Dao
ici l'avancée de la mer a englouti des
centaines de mètres de littoral ces
dernières années nombre de familles ont
déjà perdu leur maison une digue de
protection inaugurée en juillet contient
les vagues mais pourquoi combien de
temps encore pas question de partir pour
autant pour ses pécheurs traditionnels
très attachés à leur terre
nous sommes liés à jamais à la mer ici
c'est la terre de nos ancêtres on ne
connaît que la pêche on ne veut pas
vivre ailleurs
on acceptera jamais de quitter cet
endroit
d'autres n'ont pas eu le choix
Danta a perdu sa maison il y a 4 ans
importer par la mer il réside
aujourd'hui avec ses enfants dans ce cas
de réfugiés climatique
venez voir où je vis
c'est logement provisoires accueillent
quelques 1500 personnes dans des
conditions difficiles
on est coupé du monde ici il faut faire
des kilomètres pour trouver une épicerie
on a mis au ni l'électricité et il fait
beaucoup trop chaud dans ses logements
[Musique]
dans cette cité en construction financée
par le gouvernement du Sénégal et c'est
partenaires pour près de 100 millions
d'euros et l'accueillera à terme 15000
déplacés le nouveau quartier est situé à
une dizaine de kilomètres à l'intérieur
des terres loin de la mer un défi pour
attirer des pêcheurs en terme de
mobilité ça pose problème mais je pense
qu'en termes de d'amélioration des
conditions de vie donc là je dis qu'il y
a pas photo parce que on a aménagé aussi
à 100% assainissement
communauté de base tels que école
élémentaire collège poste de santé
marché les responsables espèrent que les
premiers logements sortiront de terre
dans les 8 prochains mois
et on va continuer à parler de
l'environnement avec notre invité day
Marie aida digaine cette ingénieur
sénégalais spécialisée en génie civil a
mis au point une innovation dans la
construction d'espaces de stockage en
matériaux durable bonsoir d'ailleurs
Marie Aïda digaine merci d'être avec
nous alors votre votre invention a
changé la vie des agriculteurs
pouvez-vous nous en parler nous dire
comment vous est venu l'idée de cette
invention
merci beaucoup donc merci pour cette
introduction comment m'est venue l'idée
il y a eu il y a des problématiques
environnementales majeures au Sénégal la
première problématique c'est celle de la
gestion et de la valorisation des
déchets notamment plastiques il fallait
mettre en place une solution qui va
intégrer cette problématique là on sait
que le Sénégal est un très très beau
pays mais que les déchets sont
omniprésents dans notre quotidien
notamment les déchets plastiques donc
nous avons considéré que ces déchets
n'étaient pas les déchets et des flux
sont valorisables les matériaux qu'il
fallait intégrer pour créer une solution
pour l'agriculture qui est l'une de nos
activités principales nos agriculteurs
produisent en quantité et
l'autosuffisance alimentaire et notre
objectif également au Sénégal mais nous
perdons dans des zones comme Kaya un
tiers de notre production globale
puisque nous n'avons pas d'espace de
stockage pour les conserver et pour les
commercialiser sur le marché au bon
moment c'est un pont cette solution
entre la problématique de la gestion des
déchets et celle de la perte après
récolte donc en quoi consiste cette
invention
donc nous utilisons des pneus des
bouteilles des sachets en plastique qui
sont des déchets non biodégradables que
nous intégrons dans un processus de
construction que nous avons établi donc
nous nous mettons en place en garde de
stockage avec ces matériaux là donc ce
sont des hangars de stockage 100% en
matériaux recyclé avec des matériaux
locaux également comme la terre le Tifa
etc donc c'est un processus de recyclage
qui nous permet d'avoir une enceinte de
stockage qui pour le moment peut avoir
des capacités de 100 ans de 30 40 50
tonnes selon les zones alors quels sont
aujourd'hui les difficultés des
agriculteurs liées au climat
elles sont nombreuses les difficultés
c'est d'abord la variabilité climatique
on sait aujourd'hui que les pics de
température sont extrêmement
disons fréquents on a au Sénégal deux
saisons la saison sèche et la saison des
pluies mais on voit qu'aujourd'hui ces
saisons là ne sont pas vraiment bien
définis cela veut dire qu'on a une
modification au niveau des périodes
culturelles notamment avec des
prospections comme l'oignon et la pomme
de terre nous avons le phénomène aussi
de l'ensablement dû au dépôt du sable au
niveau des des zones agricoles la
salinisation des terres qui est très
importante nous sommes dans une zone
dans essentiellement côtière donc avec
ce phénomène d'avancer de la mer nous
avons une salinisation des terres qui
est vraiment présente et ça ce n'est
plus à l'échelle disons des
hypothèses les agriculteurs disent sur
le terrain que ils n'arrivent plus à
produire correctement et au bon moment
en raison d'un changement parce qu'ils
sont en train d'observer dans leur champ
dans leur permettre agricole alors
est-ce que vous avez une autre idée
d'invention est-ce que vous travaillez
sur un autre projet pour aider ces
agriculteurs
alors nous sommes essentiellement sur
les pertes après récolte puisque nous
nous concentrons sur la problématique de
l'authuis suffisance alimentaire ce
qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'au Sénégal
nous pouvons atteindre par exemple
l'autosuffisance alimentaire dans le
domaine des pommes de terre mais nous
perdons énormément donc ces maillons de
la chaîne nous nous concentrons beaucoup
dessus bien sûr notre invention c'est
beaucoup améliorer ça fait 7 ans que
nous y travaillons nous sommes en train
de mettre en place également une
solution de suivi au niveau des
agriculteurs qui leur permettent
d'accéder à l'information climatique
puisqu'on s'est rendu compte que nous
étions en fin de chaîne presque en fin
de chaîne et qu'il fallait que les
agriculteurs et cette information là au
niveau de leurs champs pour produire au
bon moment et comprendre qu'il y a
aujourd'hui des fondements qui se
déroulent et qui peuvent perturber le
cyclo-culturel alors très rapidement
vous allez vous rendre demain charmer le
Cher quel est votre message au pays les
plus polluants notamment
mon message au pays les plus polluants
ce n'est pas un message financier c'est
le message de prise de conscience parce
que si nous ne prenons pas conscience
que notre planète est en train de
disparaître et que nous sommes tous sur
la même planète quelle que soit le pays
où nous sommes les phénomènes extrêmes
vont tous nous toucher et aujourd'hui
nous ne sommes plus à l'heure des
discussions nous sommes à l'heure de
l'action et si nous n'agissons pas nous
allons peut-être tous disparaître et les
générations futures n'existeront
peut-être pas merci donc cher pays
polluant stop stop à la pollution vous
mettez en place des solutions durables
changer le modèle de développement nous
n'en avons besoin
de passer merci beaucoup
daimariation et merci à Sarah Sakho de
nous avoir aidé à réaliser ce duplex et
la fin de journal de l'Afrique rester
avec nous l'info continue sur France 24
[Musique]